hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the fourth round of the
2022 norway chess uh the classical game
between wesley swan and vishwanathan
island ended in a draw it was an english
opening uh not a lot has happened and
after some 29 moves they agreed to a
draw so they they went into armageddon
and now as anand is leading the
tournament it would go a long way if he
gets another victory uh in round four
because he won uh all of his three
previous matches two of them in
classical one of them in rapid and now
he faces wesley so who is as you know a
very very dangerous opponent so uh
wesley for armageddon opens again with
c4 he goes for the english opening c5
same as in classical knight to c3 and
now anand doesn't go g6 but he switches
to knight to c6 so this is already
a difference from their classical game
g3 we have g6 bishop to g2 and bishop to
g7 the so-called super symmetrical line
uh b3 and now on and break symmetry he
doesn't go d6 he goes e6 and e4 by
wesley putting his pawns on light
squares and again getting control over
the d5 square uh knight to g to e7 we
have knight g to e2 and now anand
castles wesley also castles and b6 now
uh preparing to finn get to the
uh the light square bishop with a3 and
d6 now rook to b1 makes sense the bishop
is uh
slicing or the entire diagonal and you
want to move the rook and also you want
to push the pawn all the way to b4 and
here there are some games where a5 was
played but the move alan plays is a new
one he plays knights to d4 and it is now
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game so you can see um
none of them are doing anything crazy of
course wesley has to win this it's an
armageddon game and anan's position is
just very solid he has a bishop on g7 uh
he has full control over this diagonal
he has a wonderfully defended knight on
d4 the other knight is coming to c6 and
it's anand who will be controlling the
d4 square so here b4 we challenge that
control by trying to undermine the c5
pawn but just knight e to c6 and now
again even if you advance the pawn all
the way to b5 we can just trade here for
example knight captures knight captures
again knight d4 on on the wilder one
will be the one controlling the d4
square so here bishop to e3 uh charging
the knight on d4 and now bishop to d7
the bishop uh we have queen to d2 in the
now on and trades once knight captures
knight captures and knight to d4 now so
you do not want your opponent having a
knight on d4 especially if your opponent
is on and uh so let's just eliminate
that knight captures and c captures on
d4 we have bishop to h6 attacking on a
strong bishop and now e5 defending the
pawn on d4 and making uh well just
opening up the the light squares for a
light square bishop now we've placed all
of our pawns on dark squares we have a
light square bishop this is uh this is
very good on the other hand the wesley
has a light square bishop he has uh his
spawns on light square so it's not as
great but wesley has other plans for
this game he wants to push f4 open up
the position and uh start an attack he
has to win this it is an armageddon so
bishop captures king captures and now
pawn to f4
on on defense upon to f6
again the position is incredibly solid
and now wesley has to continue pushing
further he plays h4
uh we have b5 anand challenges the c4
pawn very principled your opponent
attacks on the king side you counter
attack
in the center or against the center rook
beat the c1 and b captures on c4 we have
rook captures on c4 and now okay you
could go rook to see it right away on
first challenges the rook uh we have
rook to c2 and now bishop to a4 again
asking do do you have a better square
for your rook so rook the c1 and the now
rook the c8 offering a trade of rooks
and now wesley has to continue pushing
he just plays h5 there's there's nothing
better uh g captures an h5 and accepts
the pawn sacrifice and now wesley goes
uh
after the pawn bishop to f3 queen to d7
defending by not really defending uh
because if bishop captures an h5 then
queen h3 attacks g3 and the bishop and
it's just a very very
hard to hold this
you could play g4 to keep it both but
then you go after the d3 pawn is just um
you're not going to be able to save this
so instead after queen d7 wesley goes
queen to h2 prevents the infiltration of
the queen via the h3 square and now rook
captures on c1 on unjust trains what it
trades once we have rook captures and
now rook to c8 offering a trade of the
other pair of rooks and um you can't
really trade if you go for captures
captures and then let's say queen
captures on h5 we're going to play
captures on f4 and it's uh you don't
even have to calculate this to realize
that white is not winning this you don't
know if black is winning it is but anand
only needs a draw to win the armageddon
so instead we have rook back to f1 the
rook will help out with the attack
against the black king now comes rook to
c3 uh it's very very interesting how on
the counter attacks uh
on the queen side and on the center
while being attacked on the king side
just very very instructive we have
bishop to e2 defends the pawn here and
now bishop to b5 piles up on the d3 pawn
and finally queen captures on h5 so is
it possible to grab this pawn well yes
but now you lose the d3 pawn this is
exactly what island captures bishop
captures on d3 and now wesley's position
is close to uh close to lost however
this is armageddon and
if you know you don't play perfect moves
you you might even lose a completely
winning position so here uh wesley's
best uh option here is just to capture
back and play a worse end game but of
course he doesn't want to do that he
wants to either win or lose he plays e
captures on f5 and here he managed to
completely confuse anan because anand
now has to deal with the threat of just
captures on f6 with check so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the only winning move for anand while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on playing the
cold-blooded bishop captures on e2
because that is the only move that wins
this position and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show uh bishop
captures on e2 yes that's the good stuff
uh now the thing is you have to allow e
captures an f6 with check and put your
king on h8 the only square that doesn't
lose and the point is yes your queen is
hanging but you're going to play f7 and
now if black captures the queen wesley
just delivers checkmate so that's that's
the point however it's still winning for
anand but he has to play rook captain g3
with check and now what do you play
you're going to move the king king to f2
and now only now we capture the queen
because now after uh f8 queen which is
the only move on basically the only good
move for white we're gonna play rook
here and after queen to f6 we're going
to block with queen g7 we've defended
we're up material we are completely
winning the game so that's what anand
had to play after f captures on e5 but
unmissed bishop captures on e2 because
you can see just how scary captures an
f7 is uh he played d captures on e5 and
it seems like okay nothing really
changed we just traded a little bit of
material my position is still much much
better at winning but there's a move
that on and completely missed and that
allows wesley to win the game so feel
free to pause the video for the second
time and now win the game for wesley
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting very very
difficult moves in a very very short
amounts of time and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is queen
to f3 the only move that wins now we are
threatening the f6 square and also the
bishop on d3 and there's no good way to
defend if you capture on e2 or or try to
defend the bishop uh it doesn't really
matter just queen captures king h king
the g8 and queen to f8 will be checkmate
so it's made in two
so here queen to e6 was played and has
to give up the bishop and now wasteland
just plays bishop captures on d3 so
basically by not capturing the bishop on
the blunders his own bishop so here rook
captures on a3 wesley now up a clean
piece but it's still not as easy to
convert because anand only needs a draw
so if he can create some sort of a
castle uh or or a fortress
then he still wins the armageddon game
so here we have a6
rook to f2 and now rook to b3 anand goes
after the b4 pawn bishop c4 now
wesley's still saying uh okay if you
capture then i'm still going to
checkmate you like in the previous
variation so rook captures on f3 that's
the only way to do it bishop captures on
e6 and now rook to e3 of course not
trading rooks the end game is winning
for wesley and now bishop to f5
defending the e4 pawn so now ananda does
have the past d-pawn but there's just no
good way to start pushing it we have
rook to b3 now going after the b4 pawn
and rook a2 going after the a6 pawn rook
captures on b4 rook captures on a6 and
now rook to b7
we have rook to d6 and now if the pawn
is ever pushed we can just capture it so
anan doesn't have to win this so there's
no point in trying to push the pawn he
just needs to hold to a draw uh he is up
two pawns for the bishop so maybe it's
possible uh but there is one maneuver
that allows wesley to actually win the
game so rook to a7 and now wesley starts
the king march king to h3 we have rook
to b7 king to g4 rook to a7 anand can
only repeat moves here king h5 we've
rooked to c7 and now we have rook to d8
now the idea is bishop to e6 and the
rook the g8 checkmate as the king covers
the g6 and the h6 squares so rook the e7
not allowing bishop to e6 and here
wesley just plays the very cool bishop
to g4 and he was in this position on mu
46 that vishwanathan anand resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here it's a basically uh a complete
swung there is no move you can make if
you push this pawn then we're just gonna
capture it if you move the rook from the
defending the e6 square bishop e6 is
coming and then it's game over if you
move the king then you allow king h6 and
then we again pick up the h pawn uh so
whatever you do your position just
deteriorates which is basically the
definition of a tuk tuang
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nice uh turnaround for
wesley uh this is just after bishop
captures and on d3 a completely lost
position or maybe not completely but
incredibly difficult to play wesley just
plays f captures on e5 and things just
work out for him sometimes that happens
in chess so never give up never resign
you know hope that something will happen
but i i'm pretty sure that goes for
every sport and every situation in life
as well
so yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it uh uh here are the standings
so we don't forget the standings after
the day four sorry uh it's not prepared
properly there we go uh via chess 24.
uh so a magnus carlsen caught up to
vishwanathan and now with eight and a
half points as he defeated giri after
anisha tried that queen uh queen
sacrifice or rather a queen trade for
two rooks if you guys haven't seen it do
check it out uh it's my previous video
uh wesley with uh seven and a half
points in third place mamadara with
seven in fourth maksim bashir lagrav
with five and a half in fifth anishigiri
with four uh vessel and topalov with
three and a half and with three points
in eight nine and ten van gaal arientari
and timur rajabov uh so those are the
round four standings uh so yeah once
again i really hope you enjoyed that
understandings as well i would like to
thank anand legend varun sudarsanan
richard knapp raymond young and david
kimura for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it uh as usual you can check
two of my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this amazing
event uh until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day